ce matin pascal praud donc animer un
débat dans son émission l'heure des pros
sur chenilles qui avait pour thème
d'identité française le journaliste a
réuni sur son plateau
yassine belattar eric zemmour deux
hommes que tout oppose et qui cela la
misère sans merci depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines
comment est née cette histoire on vous a
tout résumé on en parle juste après
regardez il ya des débats qui ne termine
jamais c'est comme ça qu'on pourrait
qualifier la relation entre le polémiste
eric zemmour et l'humoriste yassine
belattar ce dernier devenu da quelques
temps chroniqueur sur la chaîne info lci
a fait beaucoup parler de lui ces
derniers mois dans son viseur eric
zemmour qui selon lui ne devrait pas
avoir une telle tribune à la télévision
française zemmour me fait pas rire du
tout moi yassine belattar j'emmerde éric
zéni de ce soit très clair
le 19 février dernier alors qu'eric
zemmour était interrogé sur lci à
l'occasion d'une marche contre
l'antisémitisme
yassine belattar a choisi de
démissionner de ses fonctions pour
protester contre cette nouvelle tribune
offerte à l'écrivain s'en est suivi une
succession de pics entre les deux hommes
par médias interposés mais aussi
étonnant que cela puisse paraître malgré
ce départ pour critiquer la
surmédiatisation des idées du polémiste
yassine belattar a accepté de débattre
une dernière fois avec zemmour le tout
sur le plateau de ses news
alors les cherry on va vous faire un
petit récap de ce qui s'est passé ce
matin entre les deux c'était plus de
1h30 de débarrer entre yassine belattar
et pascal praud chez vous êtes très
nombreux à attendre notre débrief qui a
gagné le match regardé n'ont pas arrêté
de s'envoyer des piques tous les deux
eric zemmour avait démarré très fort en
taclant yacine regarde je pense que
yacine bas latin n'est pas un humoriste
qui fait rire personne
par sa mère parce qu'elle est indulgente
on a dit pas les mamans pas les freins
trauma locaux dans la main on prenait le
même chemin
vous avez pris la départementale de la
renommée du tout que vous le vouliez ou
non vous avez une tête d'arabe vous
ressembler à mon oncle mahfoud au maroc
vous êtes un faux comique et et est un
vrai militant il ya quelques jours 50
personnes sont mortes en
nouvelle-zélande en partie vous êtes
responsable de la diffusion de ces idées
moi je vous dis adieu à tous les deux je
ne ferai plus de débat voilà alors ça
s'est passé ce matin qui a gagné pour
vous ce débat qui était très très très
attendu alors on a pour vous il ya sin
bela tarr
oui je suis vraiment pas fan de ce
personnage et pourtant alors moi je vous
dis je
je le connais un peu oui même si je suis
pas d'accord avec lui sur plein de
choses et cassine c'est un bon pote à
moi
voilà je m'entends bien avec lui et
c'est un garçon qui est très dark lady
lennar car voilà il est c'est un
humoriste à la base
moi c'est voilà je vous dirais été j'ai
eu au téléphone après le truc il m'a dit
moi je suis un humoriste à la base voilà
j'ai juste envie de rigoler voilà prix
bas pour ses idées reprenez pas d'accord
sur plein de choses ans tous les deux
mais voilà c'est il arrêterait aussi
engagé politiquement et ça c'est
important après au delà de toute
considération qu'on peut une fois
partagé ce partage ici voilà il ya plein
de trucs sur lesquels je suis pas
d'accord avec lui j'ai trouvé ça un
courageux de venir sur le plateau de
débattre avec un monsieur qui ne
voulaient pas apparaître sur la même
chaîne que lui parce qu'il est quand
même parti d essayer parce qu'il voulait
pas être sur la même chaîne que lui je
les trouvais bien c'est parce qu'il a su
rester calme
tombé face à un homme comme eric zemmour
qui est une telle rhétorique est aussi
intelligent dans chacun de ses métiers
c'est très dur de passes levé d'aller
lui mettre une grosse il a su rester
calme
après effectivement il était drôle eric
zemmour je vous le dit valérie bénaïm
vraiment me connaissent et moi je te
connais pas du tout personnellement et
tout le monde me dit moi je suis
d'accord avec lui sur pratiquement rien
ben oui voilà mes eric zemmour il paraît
qu'il est délicieux dans la nuit paraît
que c'est un garçon que tout le monde
adore ça c'est très longtemps que je
n'ai pas vu
effectivement il est très agréable quand
on le côtoie et ce qu'il adore cette
discuter il pourrait discuter avec mes
donc c'est pour ça ni d autant de trucs
pour énerver il adore la discussion et
un échange intellectuel c'est toujours
intéressant en échanges intellectuels
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec vous
trouvez que c'est lui qui a remporté le
gp pour ça alors je parle pas du fond
bien évidemment parce que je pense que
des deux côtés le seul gagnant
s'arrêtait pascal praud gagnon s'est pas
vraiment celui qui a gagné
je pense que de deux côtés il y avait
des outrances et de deux des deux côtés
y avait de la caricature quand il ya
c'est quand eric zemmour dia yassine
belattar avec une grande violence
votre prénom n'est pas un prénom
français dont vous n'êtes pas français
vous êtes disqualifié
c'est une énorme violence quand yassine
belattar dit à eric zemmour vous avait
du sang sur les mains c'est qu'une
immense violent il quand il enregistre
lui a dit il lui a dit c'est vous qui
êtes responsable de l'attentât la
nouvelle saison passée voilà au sérieux
si c'était malvenu que c'était vraiment
voilà dans les deux cas y avait
énormément de et donc je pense qu'il y
en a un qui est un peu meilleur thé aux
théoriciens et pv de la langue qui sait
mieux manier la langue que l'autre il a
cité eric valmir x et on sait que ça ici
c'est donc lundi 29 cents alors c'est
moi c'est son métier et une mathieu
données rares cafés pascal praud et
qu'elle fait déjà redit son avec ap
c'est tout c'est que quand on est face à
eric zemmour qui est un puits de culture
et dont je déteste les idées et compris
celles de marine le pen on met pas en
face quelqu'un de peu cultivés ou un
humoriste il faut mettre en place des
gens qui sont extrêmement cultivé pour
vernon n'est justement la contrevérité
et pour être en face ils étaient bons
mais ils n'avaient pas la culture d'eric
zemmour il a trahi hassine aussi ses
listes et puis ça va me démerder
mais évidemment ils n'avaient pas la
culture pour répondre à eric zemmour
tout comme ap7 tous n'avaient pas la
culture pour répondre à face à eric
zemmour
il faut un nadal de la culture générale
voilà un humoriste alors qui veut région
nature vraiment j'ai redit avoir ton
avis là dessus toi moi j'ai dit yassine
belattar même si au début j'ai pas aimé
je veux en mettre un peu à yassine
belattar sur ce qu'il a dit sur
l'attentât qui a eu lieu ici même lui je
pense qu'il a bouclé un accord il pense
qu'il a là et je sais qu'il faut sur ce
qui dit il veut nier certaines évidences
comme il dit qui se passe rien dans les
quartiers si dans les quartiers il ya
des filles qui sont embêtés qui seront
peut-être un petit pas receler il ya il
ya des prières de rue parce qu'il n'ya
pas les lieux qui sont faits pour ça il
ya aussi du on a vu la france changé il
y en a vu le halal arrivée dans les
supermarchés tout ça ça a changé mais
c'est la france cachant mais quels
étaient les problèmes de vol
il est de temps en temps moi que moi de
voir du casher du halal danone est en
marche et non mais c'est juste pour dire
que zemmour c'est ce qu'ils disent ça ça
a changé et yassine belattar parfois il
veut pas le reconnaître mais j'ai dit
pourquoi yassine belattar parce que
zemmour de l'autre côté à chaque fois
c'est une bête médiatique il a il a une
connaissance des peuples qui est
impressionnant il connaît les histoires
de tous mais oui mathieu quand tu vas en
face de lui était en galère et j'aime
pas les amalgames qui fait quand il dit
que il ya 720 720 quartiers qui sont
gangrenées par l'islamiste et la drogue
pourquoi il mélange les deux camps
yacine il lui dit pourquoi vous faites
l'amalgamé entre la drogue et l'islam il
répond il ya 80% de détenus en milieu
carcéral qui sont musulmans
pourquoi il fait ça pourquoi il dit dans
les quartiers en banlieue il ya plus de
juifs il ya plus de chrétiens
mais ces articles vous avez volé nos
voitures et vous avez violé leur fille
ça c'est du vol n aux autoradios hélas
pas droit d'une personne pour lui
répondre oui là mais moi j'aurai si
j'avais le temps mais j'étais en tournée
avec le camion mais il n'a pas droit de
dire vous avez violé le fil après moi
j'ai envie de dire à zemmour la france à
la changer la france c'est comme ça tu
pourras rien y faire louis de funès et
le corniaud s'est passé maintenant tout
le monde est là essayons de vivre
ensemble j'ai passé une caméra eric
zemmour est d'attiser la haine 30 ans 30
ans qui sont passés avec la france que
tu nous racontes n existe plus tard
france bien on essaye de vivre ensemble
et moi
béja cuisine je prends juste du débat en
lui même sur le débat j'ai trouvé que
zemmour était meilleur parce qu'ils
étaient dans l'action c'est ses
propositions ses remarques qui fondait
le débat alors que yassine belattar
n'était que dans la réaction
donc je les trouvais très en dessous il
faut savoir aussi qui avait pas du tout
de fait qu ils se détestent vraiment ils
se sont pas serré la main avant le débat
à d'accord il est frais et après n'ont
pas non plus connaissance non plus et
j'ai eu pro pour lui ces matches nuls il
a trouvé que les deux qui est assez bon
et m'a dit pour moi c'est match nul
précieux vous dire je lis la vérité
voilà je je je pense que je suis
d'accord avec les doublons les idées ni
lundi ni lundi dont les idées vraiment
mais j'ai trouvé eux parce que chez nous
on savait qu'il était bon il ya trouvé
yassine belattar assétou non je pensais
pas que voilà maintenant qu'il a fermé
la gueule à beaucoup de monde qui
pensait que c'est un charlot et qui la
disent prendre une grosse raclée face à
ces mots je trouve qu'ils sont nés
plutôt pas mal sorti avec deux trois
pôles klein qui était assez drôle
voilà en tout cas on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec eux sur les idées mais en
tout cas ce qu'ils essaient sortie
encore ce matin c'est que le débat et
est sorti gagnant et je vous le dis
c'est parce qu'elle prouve une fois de
plus pour avoir adoré parce qu'après
parce qu' il a été exceptionnel il n'a
pratiquement pas parlé et c'est là où il
a été très fort on va dire qu'il ya des
mecs qu'ils auraient voulu tirer la
couverture à eux dire voilà vous avez vu
c'est moi je veux donner mon avis de ça
il les a laissés débattre il a fait un
début une fin et la fait deux trois
petites relances on l'a pas entendu le
recevrez un emballant son format web on
passe pas un mois mais rien d'emballant
ton post eric zemmour bien sûr eric
simmons & gas inc antivol yacine j'ai
peut-être d'ailleurs je vais peut-être
lui proposer de venir d'ailleurs je dis
ok qu'on fera un gros truc sur sur le
livre qui est sorti sur le front
national il ya des révélations
étonnantes et d'ailleurs j'ai même
inviter marine le pen à venir parce que
j'aimerais qu'elle vient nous expliquer
toutes les révélations sont faites dans
ce livre pour l'instant
elle n'a pas répondu donc j'appellerai
demain d'ailleurs montrerai le coup de
fil en direct les chéris eric zemmour
qui a gagné eric zemmour yassine
belattar yassine belattar pour nos
téléspectateurs insisté sur les cds
pense voilà dans mesrine sont les idées
voilà pour les est bon au niveau du
débat je trouve qu'il a été ces mots on
sait qu'il est bon en débat c'est
c'est comme si tu dit nadal il est bon
sur terre battue bah ouais